Welcome. Um
So,
the talk is building an ICP on uh at
Open Clo. It's uh also about other
things like how to
uh put open source agents on open source
agent frameworks on Kubernetes and
stuff. So, I'm I'm I hope uh
to I will today share in a nice way what
I've been working on in the last 2
months.
Um
A little bit about me, very brief.
My uh
A little bit about me. I've been
building harnesses since a few months
before ChatGPT came out. I built a
Jupiter Lab extension over OG Codex
model like DaVinci Code 2.
Um back in the days that eventually So,
I'm currently working for a startup um
that that initial coding harness turned
into its current harness over time like
a ship of Theseus. It got ripped apart
and put back together so many times.
And uh yeah, I'm a founding engineer
there. I've been uh
in the industry since 3 and 1/2 years.
I've using Open Clo since Clo Bot uh
first dropped in Discord. I went in
there. I've been following Peter since
he wrote a Clo code is like computer. I
was like
w- this guy is crazy.
Uh because uh Clo forced on it like I
wouldn't give my machine to it, but he
he went he ventured for it and he's
paved the way for us. And when I saw uh
Clo Bot in Discord, my mind was blown.
The next day I installed it uh at the
company
uh at at in our like uh cluster.
Uh it was
basically talking to people on Discord
and also everybody else's minds were
blown. And we were
like we have the we're used to selling
the enterprise for a few
years now. So, that's why I started by
adding in MS Teams integration in case
it might be useful at some point. And I
became a maintainer along the way. I was
there when it was renamed uh two times.
Um and today I I my focus is on agent
interoperability and orchestration.
Um
like one of my goals is accelerate
enterprise adoption of Open Claw and
adjacent software and also address, you
know, Open Claw's not secure.
Well, it'll be secure or
Peter talked a lot about that earlier,
so I don't have anything else to add on
top of it. Like it's work in progress.
Sorry.
I'll use this.
So, uh it started by I started on
develop workflows right away, so I
created a PR. Uh and then call it
Discord driven development. Well,
Telegram driven development suits better
because it's TDD, so
uh
and then uh
right after I set it personally and I
realized, you know, Opus is not so
reliable for complex it wasn't back in
the days. It's now better. It's agents
are improving, but Codex was main my
main harness and I wanted to use Codex
in Discord.
But it was basic I was telling I was
playing the telephone game. I was
telling Opus to tell Codex to do
something. God knows what it's saying,
you know, because wording matters when
prompting, but it was working somehow
and I would go uh and then look at the
Codex session and then it paraphrased
kind of what I was saying, but
eventually, you know, uh I got some
stuff done, but I knew this could be
done much easier.
Um
and today I'm uh running a full IDE on
Discord like uh you know we have
parallel workloads. You have like one to
five like five channels at any point I'm
working with one to five agents.
Um
so you see Codex one to five and then
close it for testing the open close ACP
feature.
And then the basically that's how my
that's how my channels look like. And
it's very good for coding on the go
because I have I'm a guy who's addicted
to side projects and uh
I I like to just
you know uh
AI is making thing
making things a lot easier to do these
sort of things like in parallel you have
an inspiration you execute on a weekend
and you just get it ready. You ship it.
ACPX which I'm going to talk about is is
like similar. I built it through uh
Discord. And what you do is uh you bind
the channel
uh
Discord channel to Codex through ACP.
You can also use Codex app server
protocol. Harold another maintainer uh
developed it. And here it is me using it
before I flying to London to create an
PDF about like convert the docs of ACP
into PDF. And then I have to say put it
in temp because
open the uh
Codex doesn't know about the harness and
it cannot send me in Discord. So I then
I go to another channel and tell it to
send it to me on that channel. So we are
developers and our tools we don't have
time to polish them very well but we
know the
like advantages and disadvantages. What
is ACP? So it's not uh most people say
is it like MCP? MCP for is for giving
tools to the model. ACP's for uh
like
standardizing agent to client
interaction. It's uh shoutout to Zed. I
actually forgot to put Zed logo. Um
Zed is building a new editor in Rust
more efficient like lower memory usage
not Electron.
So uh I'm using Zed also since like uh
last fall and uh
you know, if you use Codex on VS Code or
Cloud Code, they are all building
different plugins. It's not exactly It's
like so much wasted work. If only you
could just standardize them under one
interface and you just build it once and
then you you ship it. And that's what
the I the idea That's the idea they had.
It's also more
It's
It's much less duplicate duplicated
work.
Um
There are competing standards. Uh so
agent like agent to
agent protocol, that's for agent talking
to agent. ACP, agent client protocol, is
for
human talking to agent, but
agent can use the human one to talk to
other agents as well.
In the long run, as as these protocols
get adopted, we will support all of
them. We will weigh the
you know,
the advantages and then we will use them
somehow.
But when I need So, I chose ACP because
when I needed the most, I needed
adapters for Codex and Cloud Code and
only that had built them and Google
didn't have them back back back at the
time, so
that's why I chose it.
Uh
that So, I
when you're adding in functionality to
Open Clo, you do uh
you use do it through a CLI.
Um
So, I said, "Okay, let's create a CLI
for ACP. Let's Let's agent call any
other agent over the command line."
So, that's that's how it started. Uh
And it's slowly turning into a Swiss
Army knife for ACP as I will show in a
bit.
So, in at Open Clo, you have fire hoses.
Uh we have 60 KPRs uh over 60 KPRs
total. 300 to 500 per day on average are
open.
And basically, overnight, people woke up
and decided they want they like open
claw. So, we have tens of thousands of
stakeholders who want to add features
to open claw. And the biggest challenge
of the project currently is how do you
absorb all the needs and wants of these
people? And how do you balance them? How
do you
Like you can't please everyone. And how
do you create an elegant system without
creating AI slop? Uh
that can cater everyone's needs. And
Peter's workflow gave me an idea. So,
this is also something I do. You go and
you ask your clanker, what is this This
is where PR comes your way. And like
most of the time it's AI generated
description. Like what is this?
Uh if the human put thought into it,
great. But like yeah, you need to ask
what it's doing. You ask, what is this
the best possible fix?
Most of the time it's no. And then
you either continue this like he he
wrote it. Like You you do some back and
forth with the agent. The reason is
people just
run into an issue with their open claw.
And it's it's going to use GitHub. And
then they just say,
"Please fix." And then they just send
some slop your way. You know, this is
You can't merge it, but you can also
fully discard it. You need to take this
data point. You It's like crucial
feedback from the user. Uh so, you need
to put it categorize it put it in a bin,
you know. It tells you when some part of
the code is broken. And Vincent also
talked about that a little bit.
Uh and here is
uh his his code extension doing that. On
one side there's the one that says it's
it's a good fix. Uh and on this other
side it's just saying it's not bad.
And
it's just so mechanical and you you once
you
do this over and over you realize you're
repeating something. If only you could
program something to automate it. So,
you're automating the automator. Um so,
I created I started uh to create like
workflows uh
in an abstract way.
So,
uh item comes PR and then you find the
intent. You're judging implementation.
You're like
uh looking in if it if it has conflicts.
Uh
if reviews gives you like some issues
that need to be addressed.
So,
you need to make the CI pass if it's not
passing already. Most people just don't
care about that. All this mechanical
work by the time the main the PR ends up
in front of you, should be resolved
ideally and can be resolved and that's
what I'm working on.
Ah, in the workflow we have the shameful
uh Ralph review refactor loops. Uh I I'm
a believer that, you know, when people
say like
give the
just just run a running a agent in a
loop doesn't not necessarily have to be
a
uh something that will create slope. As
long as you're not making it design
something, but you're making it uncover
shallow bugs that can be easily fixed
should be fine. So,
in the abstract workflow that I created
uh
which is actually called like for like
turning to a program,
you can uh tell it to uh do superficial
refactors and then you can tell if it's
it needs a fundamental refactor relate
to the human.
Um resolving conflicts also doesn't need
like No, it was hard back in the days. I
don't think anyone is like resolving
conflicts by hand by now. Um
So, we are
basically creating a standard operating
procedures for agents. That's a fancy
word for workflow. Um so, that's what I
built into ACP-X. Uh it's a an A10-like
workflow engine.
Uh but it's driving a Codex session. You
you see on the right. Let me show you in
action.
So, this was one PR.
It's loading. Let's speed it up a little
bit. So, there is some programmatic
parts.
So, this is just replaying what it's
doing.
It's reproducing the bug. It's judging
refactor.
It's reviewing. I'm doing a review loop.
And then review didn't bring anything.
It It's what I do, but I make it output
like JSON structured data so I can put
it in like an an it's unlike workflow.
And
I will talk, you know, this is a general
workflow engine. Engine.
Um
You can use it on other things as well.
Like you need to apply
agents
generously
on problems. So, I see it's like an
ointment that you apply to generously on
any problem that can be solved with
agents. You need to take yourself out of
the loop and solve it with agents.
Um and personal agents, I think are on a
like there there's spectrum enterprise
and personal agent.
And
normally you see the work you use at the
computer and then the PC the PC use at
work.
And the PC use at at home
used to be relatively similar, but that
will not be the case with agents because
at at work
you will be using consuming a lot more
inference.
And that means in enterprise there will
be a lot more money to be made.
So, that's why I'm a bit also excited
about enterprise agents and open close
a potential.
That's why I I believe in
on-demand disposable agents. If you use
open clone slack or teams or discord,
this is one instance. You create an app.
The problem is you can't really talk to
multiple instances
of this
um
like
you create an a connection, you create a
Slack app to connect another agent and
another name and another uh profile
picture, you need to create another app.
You have to create an app manifest. And
it's it's it's something that shouldn't
be managed manually by clicking. And the
platforms like chat apps don't have the
standard yet where you can uh mult- do
multi-agent provisioning, like
cosmetically create different agents.
This is what This is on on the screen
you see I asked ChatGPT to generate the
idea. You have an agent
uh and then the name can be generated by
an an underlying app, and you can talk
to them separately. This is not
supported, and this must be supported
for this uh vision to work. Until it's
supported, I'm using it on another UI.
Because like we are all going to start
one uh agent per task, and there will be
uh
they will work on these tasks, and they
will be creating files, editing files,
and it will all be synchronized. It will
be
it will be uh tied with different than
what you're used to with your uh
personal agent. And to do to have that,
you need to have co- like a few key
components. You need to have Kubernetes.
You need to uh have an agent harness.
Open Cloak could be one of them. Codex
Cloud Code could be one of them. Could
be a CP Could be uh GitHub.
Uh
you give read write access, and you do
like state data synchronization. Like
you maybe you do something that's use
rsync.
Some something like what uh whatever
algorithm Dropbox is using. And there
are some projects that are uh taking
this on. I've been working on this uh
this is outside of Open Cloak. This is
my day job. And uh
it's an open source uh orchestrator.
Uh it's the goal operator that's uh,
basically handles the complicated parts.
You know, there's a user experience.
You want to create a concierge on Slack.
Like concierge agent and you're talking
to it, but you get bottleneck because
you have 100 employees on Slack. So, you
need to do for for some other task, you
may you may need to create a new one and
then it creates and gives you like a
website link. Um,
I'm going to skip the
like shout-outs to Cognition and Devin
um,
because uh, yeah, they invented the
category, but I'm running low on time.
So, the repo is at text cortex sprits.
I'm just going to uh, demo it for our
use case.
We use it on error reporting uh,
currently.
So, if you're on Slack, you know, uh,
you can ask it to dispatch an agent to
debug it, you know, you're like, "I'm
uh, asking any new bugs after prod
release." And it's got saying something.
And then you ask it uh, to create an
agent. Uh, if I could put it that agent
into Slack, I would, but I can't do
that.
So, I have to put it in another UI.
And this is an open source project. You
can take this uh, UIs also
uh,
like a react app hosted in the cluster
that you're deploying this these helm
charts to. And uh,
yeah, you
you it starts the conversation there. It
starts working on the uh, problem. This
is like codex web or Devin or anything,
but it's actually using like a
full Kubernetes pod.
Wasteful, but I think it's the better
abstraction because open core showed the
power, you know, when you give a full
computer to an agent, it's a lot more
powerful. Um, and I I believe that as
well.
Um, I uh,
I I think uh,
open hands uses firecracker. So, I'm
also uh,
not so well versed on all the different
virtualization frameworks.
Uh
So, it's I'm also learning along the
way, but I have a working product that's
running on Kubernetes.
Uh and
you can use this
uh product uh
you can if you're interested in
deploying internally and
using Codex on the web. Uh and then you
just spin things off if you like, I
don't know, a back-end uh
If if you have an open-source project,
first of all, I can help you set this
up. If you have a system like inlets of
just
100 of hundreds of issues per day, I can
help you process it.
Um
this is uh
that does all the wiring around Slack
and like keeping those agents
like on
and the user experience and then the
the interoperability. You're not locked
in any in any agent. You can switch.
It's all abstract the way
build
with ACP.
Yeah.
That was my talk. Uh thank you for
listening. Some social links in case you
want to
uh get in contact with me. I just want
to make clear like of my uh
the OpenFlow uh side and TextCortex
side.
Uh so, this the last part was TextCortex
about the work I do at TextCortex.
Uh just to give a disclaimer.
Um thank you for listening.
I guess
Yeah.
Well.
Thank you.